imagine imagine you're at your wedding
and next man screams baby please
on his hands and knees
please baby don't do this
i would be
mortified
[Music]
what is good
cult members vlog one people how we
doing hope you men are blessed
um as always guys
we love that you're here to join us
today um if you are a true culti then
you will already know what i'm about to
say but if you're new here that's
absolutely fine all you need to do is
quickly pause this episode right now
head on over to patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs and over there
you're gonna find over two years
worth of uh episodes that me and food
have done um in secret and only the true
fans
and the true fans know and the only way
you can access that guys is paying three
pound a month
10p a day yeah if you nearly had a sip
of drink and missed it uh three pound of
my tempe a day and uh
guys you can enjoy a new episode every
single thursday as well as two years of
backlog as well as all the other
discounts and first dibs and zoom calls
and all the other fun stuff two years of
backlogs a lot of backlog guys like if
you guys are one of those people that
have just binged through our episodes
you found us on tiktok or you found us
on wherever you're just like binge and
binge and bitchin and you so happen to
be up to date
we've got episodes on patreon episodes
on patreon there's episodes on patreon
so as jimmy said patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs you know the vibes
that's where you need to be
that's the next step that is the next
step and we've got a healthy base of uh
like-minded people over there so you
don't enjoy yourself you do jump in the
comments and have a fun discussion
um on top of that guys if you are
listening on spotify or any other uh
place where you get your podcast please
follow the page or subscribe to the page
and leave a review and it does wonders
for us it helps us so much
reach the masses and build this cult to
the level that we really need it to be
um if you're watching us on youtube make
sure you
like and subscribe and hit the
notification bell and whilst you're
there chirp sitting in the comments
always um this is better than tinder
it's better than him
bumble it's better than all them thing
there plenty of fish yeah plenty of food
shits and gives comments is where the
love connections are made yeah man so
jump in there and uh chirps a ting and
enjoy yourself
all right guys without any further ado
let's head on over to who had for his
fun fact so yo so today's fun fact is
about limb lengthening have you heard
about this
um to make yourself taller i o i have
where they uh so let me get this before
you say it this is what i think happens
right
so i'm pretty sure
they break the bone entirely
and um
pull it apart so they break it pull it
apart like half a centimeter or whatever
and then it regrows longer and then they
break it pull it apart re-grows longer
that's not the one i've seen oh god go
on so i'm gonna read this and i'm gonna
go to a side note as well so limb
lengthening is the latest surgery trend
and becoming more popular worldwide the
surgery involves having your bones
extended and enables you to increase
your height by up to five inches so
don't you worry about height that is a
lot of fight james but yeah go go go
what
risks
of the surgery include
bone growth restriction which may cause
short height the first one
bone infection
injury to blood vessels
poor bone healing and nerve damage say
less is it worth it stay short is it
worth it brother because what i've read
is that they they break it like you said
but they put a little ting inside that
extends over a period of time and then
it heals around that
so it's it's all
risk k oh fam and imagine the thing is
on top of all those risks
you're in a wheelchair for god knows how
long for so long yeah you can't run
properly you can't exercise properly you
can't let alone walk properly for so
long months afterwards you can't walk
properly this is what women have done to
us
because i know women aren't taking the
surgery
they don't need them
their client base has zero women
zero women it's all guys it's all the
land it's all guys that are trying to
catch some nun and have been told if
you're not six foot then don't bother
don't bother swiping right it's just
impossible for us to
make you happy if you're not over six
foot bro it's impossible and i saw a
tick tock the other day right this is so
funny there was a guy doing these on the
street interviews yes
and um he said he's like six three six
four he was tall
i think i've seen this but he pulled it
as a white guy he's the one with the
white guy white guy
pen girl okay a courtroom a night out
fam he said what do you look for in a
guy she said height
height literally just high how tall oh
six three say gang so as long as they're
taller than you she said yeah have to be
taller than me because i'm however much
height and i'm wearing heels okay so i'm
like a solid six one six two as it is it
has to be at least six three the guy was
like a healthier amount taller than her
she said you don't care about face you
don't care about this she said i don't
give a [ __ ] as long as you're taller
than me we can we can do it we say gang
can i have your number she said no
she said nah
she literally said as long as you're
taller than me listen it can pop he says
can it pop and she said nah listen this
this brings me on to my next thing i saw
this video it's about like zodiac
science and it was like a have you seen
the video it's about like
men and women
there's
males and females having a group
discussion about zodiacs one of the
birds like let's not even [ __ ] do
this because it means nothing yeah watch
how the conversation unfolds is
basically is basically what you said
they say what they want they say they
really want these things but they're
chatting [ __ ] they're just chatting [ __ ]
yeah cool
let me pull it up can we ask the zodiac
signs real quick oh my god no bro
no bro that [ __ ] does not matter it's
not true bro
i like when people guess yes okay how do
you feel when girls be saying that
though i feel like
i feel like a lot of the [ __ ] that you
say is going to be in [ __ ] valley
that's exactly what i was like because
it's like this if you wanted to guess my
sign and i told you you say oh i think
you're a cancer and i'll be like no i'm
a taurus
are you yes i'm a taurus
do i do i act
you do
i do yeah i'm not a [ __ ] tourist
[Music]
you see what i'm saying yes i say i'm
not a [ __ ] tourist like they're just
like gasps yeah again because like i
feel like you're a taurus i can see it
but it doesn't matter what you are like
um people just try all
i say people like they just try and
[ __ ]
put
star signs in a box like a category like
someone message me it doesn't matter
someone messaged me that the other the
day they don't matter and was like oh
you give off i'm so sorry like to
message you like whatever randomly but
you give give me something i think it
was aries you give me mad aries vibes
like you must be areas i was like no i'm
i am a tourist like i was like now i'm a
tourist and she and then she was like oh
okay fair enough and i can't i said
something like
derogatory comment about it
um and she was like that's such a
tourist thing to say
sure you just you just said i act like
an aries so make your [ __ ] mind shut
up
shut up because everyone acts like
anyone if you want it to be you
know you're going to make me fit in a
box literally so it's just oh sharp man
star signs and all that it's just it's
all dumb and the whole bro the heart
literally that tick tock showed me that
like the whole height thing is [ __ ]
[ __ ] if i'm taller than you then
shut up
that's all we should be discussing if
i'm taller than you shut up
shut up
because all this six one two three four
you don't know what you're on about you
don't even know what 16 looks like you
literally don't
draw it for me
mark me where 63 is because you don't
even know you don't know and you don't
lick you literally don't care
you're just saying [ __ ] women just say
[ __ ] because that's what happens when
you know when like um
you know this is like perfect like you
know when people are rich yes and then a
lot of the things the biggest thing that
wealth gets you is options
yeah so when we people are wealthy
there's a thing right so um i was
listening to a pocket years ago
and it was talking about like
lamborghinis or ferraris or whatever
some guy uh on the show just got ferrari
and as soon as he got it he put on his
instagram and everyone's messaging him
like ah if i had that kind of money i
would never waste it on a ferrari
it's like his response was you would
never buy ferrari because you're never
gonna have ferrari money when you
actually have ferrari money and you've
already got seven cars that you would
actually get and you've still got so
much money
tell me you wouldn't buy a ferrari
because you've got ferrari money facts
that's women
that is a a remotely paying woman is
that they just say [ __ ] and do [ __ ] and
it doesn't really matter because you can
buy a ferrari and be like turns out i
don't like ferraris but it doesn't
matter because i've got ferrari money
that's exactly what it's like to be a
woman in that it's just like
i want us a guy a six three and like you
don't even know what guy a six three
looks like you don't care if he treats
you better than that and they're like
yeah yeah run me a guy six six three and
then they get a guy at six freedom block
nah and then everyone all the guys are
there like but you said this and they
said
i've got ferrari money which means i've
got like double d tits yeah
i've got six three [ __ ]
i have six three [ __ ] so i'm allowed to
say i want a guy to six three and i know
a guy who is who is six three will
magically appear and then i also have
the power to be like boring next
because i've got six three [ __ ] i've
got dms to go through
i've got dms to go through options do
you think it's only you
james you think it's only you
[ __ ] you and you're six too
[ __ ] you and your fireball
boring me brother
you're boring me
literally
literally options
ah
shank in a twist bam shank twist die
just die there just bleed out and die
yeah and guys can
scream from the bleachers as much as
they were it's not going to change
anything
we can have as many of these episodes as
we want to have it's not going to change
anything
it's not going to change anything yeah
we just have to firm it
there's certain things that guys just
had to take else on and i'm willing to
accept that
as long as women are willing to accept
their l's yeah
yeah yeah there was a girl who wanted to
beef me in my dms a few weeks so i never
told you about this okay she wanted to
beef me about my dm's a few weeks ago
about
about um
hype okay so it was nothing to do with
my insecurity about my height but she
tried to tell me
if i'm not attracted to a girl who's
taller than me
it is a direct insecurity of my own
height
i mean that's false
i literally was like untrue that was
very false but for some reason i was in
the mood to debate okay
when you're in the mood
you know when i'm in the mood to go we
can go
i was literally in tesco i put my basket
down
we can do this
so i said to her all right elaborate
she was like well any guy
um
any guy who's etc what whatever height
if he's taller than a guy like a girl
could be six foot if a guy's six five
he's not going to care if the girl six
foot i was like also false
very false also very fast because you're
already
negating your own argument that you're
basically saying as long as i'm taller
than you then you should accept me
because you're saying if a guy is taller
than the girl then he won't care then
surely that should work to work vice
versa and any girl who's five five or
five four five three or five six or five
eight whatever should accept me
is exactly what you're saying
so your your immediate argument is
already diminishing your main argument
yeah
and she was like nah nah nah because
exercise and then
she was like i was like that's not true
like any guy who's six five can decide i
only like guys girls who are five two
and like that's within our right yeah
and she tried to tell me it's not within
our right because guys impose so many
beauty standards on women
already based on this and that and this
and that and fam i was i can't even
remember what i said but i was literally
like
cool you've lost your argument now yeah
you've lost your argument now as soon as
you've taken it away from our immediate
argument about height and have now
categorized all guys
as
beauty shaming or whatever women in
historical signs like you've lost
because you literally can't stick to the
argument
you've you've brought an argument to me
which negates your own argument i've
made you aware of your own hypocrisy and
now you've changed it to the [ __ ]
now you've changed that's spewing off
and now you're talking about the
generation generational issue between
beauty standards she's fighting she's
you're boring me
i'd literally say you're boring me and
you've lost so now i'm going to delete
this conversation and get on with my
shopping trip bye bye femme she was vet
replies i was like bye
bye i think i replied lol yeah fact she
sent me like nine things lol i didn't
even read them i just said i would have
sank it a twist ah so like i said i'm
willing to accept the fact yeah yeah
that that girls have six three [ __ ]
yeah so it doesn't matter if i'm taller
than you richer than you funnier than
you whatever if you decide you want a
guy a six three not even know what that
looks or feels like you have that right
because you've got six three [ __ ] and i
am just a guy in the queue waiting to
get his chance if that's what you want
to do and when to accept that as long as
women women are willing to accept
that if i say i don't want a girl who's
taller than me stay out of my dms don't
try and beat me about it if i'd randomly
say you know what i don't i would never
date a girl who's six six foot
if you as soon as you enter my dms and
say
well you were never blah blah blah blah
you are now one of you've now joined the
men in these bleachers yeah who are
fighting for the sixth three [ __ ]
you've you're now one of them because
i have that right
with regardless if i never [ __ ] another
girl as long as i live yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i have the right to be like
nah if you're taller than me it's your
business you can call me shortly you
want but i'm saying that because
what you're basically saying as soon as
you enter my dm and say well that's not
fair because this is a you're basically
saying i'm desperate to [ __ ] you and i
can't because you've decided that i'm
too tall for you now you want to flip it
on me and say i'm too short for you but
the fact that you're here means i'm not
yeah
yeah
the fact that you're here right here
your means you're not
so head upstairs to the bleachers and
wait your turn yeah
i'm going to accept that yeah because i
have i have literally taken it within my
heart and realized that we just don't as
soon as a girl says six three
there's no point argue you're basically
arguing with the bouncer to get in the
club
it's just never gonna happen yeah it's
never gonna happen you can be jordan
peterson
yeah you're not invited fair enough
you're not fam you're literally not on
the guest list you can run your mouth as
long as you want you're not on the guest
list
so firm and move on [ __ ]
tough titties ma'am tough time
uh we're going to move on to um a little
posting that i told you about yeah yeah
yeah yeah um so i think a few of you
guys sent this to me
um either send it to me or send it to us
or both
um shade room put up a little ting cool
so the shadroom posted or someone on
twitter posted
um
wait have you guys ever witnessed
someone objecting at a wedding please
share because i feel like i've never
heard stories about it and the shade
room someone sent this to me but i
didn't look at the shade room we posted
it some of the responses are juicy go
juice
go go go go go go go go go go
so when my aunt remarried one of her
baby daddies one of her other baby
daddies objected and said his said his
reason for objecting is that she was a
hoe and not meant for marriage
everybody just looked at each other
because we already knew what my aunt was
no
fam
not quite an objection
in brackets and not the wedding i was at
close brackets but i was a bridesmaids i
was a bridesmaid at a venue and the
event planner was spilling the tea about
a precocious wedding
whole ceremony happened bride and groom
got married right towards the end of the
speeches at the reception the groom
stood up the groom stood up and said
something like i'd like to thank my
beautiful bride and my best man for
sleeping together for six months oh
my god then he walked out apparently all
hell broke loose afterwards fights
between families and all
imagine keeping that for six months just
to wait to your wedding day couldn't
i literally i couldn't
so
from the day he found out he knows his
wife is still clapping my boys
that's literally like me finding out
that you're banging my fiance and we
just keep doing this part week on week
on week on week and week i just don't
say anything until i decide to say
something that's in you're a psychopath
psychopath bro
that doesn't cycle
you can't keep that information in i
could never keep that information in
fighting you the second i find out
the moment we lock eyes it's on it has
to be on it has to be
it literally
three years ago at my wedding as they
were saying their vows the groom's
ex-girlfriend walks in and claims
they've been [ __ ] for the past six
months and she's pregnant with twins
they called off the wedding come to find
out she was [ __ ] his twin brother the
entire time
wasn't even him
wow
my late aunt crashed my uncle's wedding
and said she was pregnant with his kid
the wedding got cancelled
he married her instead they never had
the baby and they stayed married until
they died
stop everything
stop everything
stop everything stop everything stop
everything hang on let me pull that back
bro he's getting i'm getting married my
late aunt crashed my uncle's wedding
i'll say it slower for the people in the
back
and she said she was pregnant with his
kid
the wedding was cancelled he married her
instead she never had a baby and stayed
married until they died that's
wow
wow
this is why women think they can get
away with this they can get with murder
just man she just she just rocked up and
lied just rocked up and said i'm
pregnant and it's yours
say something cancel everything a man
said i'mma do what's right i'll marry
you instead there was no baby there was
never a baby and they died together wow
she said i'm having you no matter what
that's [ __ ] insanity
when i was attending hillman university
my re i don't know what r.a is was
getting married and some guy interrupted
the wedding talking about baby please it
was wild i think there's a video online
somewhere i don't know
imagine
imagine you're at your wedding and next
man screams baby please
on his hands and knees
please baby don't do this
i would be
mortified
i will look at him and then look at her
baby with chests baby please don't do
this
in front of my friends and my family in
front of my mum and my dad my dad could
never look me in the eye never my dad
could never look at me
my dad could never let me an eye baby
please
baby
he's shouting to the heavens baby please
don't do this
i couldn't believe why i read james oh
the wedding
there's not there's not enough
um
scenarios like this i need more of this
fam right i need more of this oh my god
because this is toxic but juicy
baby please baby please
not even a first name not even not even
sarah please don't do this
baby please don't do this strawberry
second or third row he's close
stomach said baby please don't do this
oh my god everyone in the reception
gasps i wouldn't know what to do family
i couldn't look my groomsman in the face
that's who i
that's who i couldn't face i couldn't
have you j rem tomes and all you man
looking at me i wouldn't be able to look
back brother we'll be laughing so hard
one of you 100 jay will grab my shoulder
like this it grips it if i soak it in
grab your trash all right it's all right
that's right we'll get them off me and
rem will be on our knees crying
me and rem will be on our knees chrome
laughter and toby we're gonna like stop
you man
oh look it's a massive baby
a massive baby
i'll be like who's baby oh look at my
wife like who's baby
fam i'd flip the whole oh oh 100
baby
with chet you had the goal to say that
in front of me about my wife
baby all right random question this has
just made me think about this random
question let's say you've been married
but unfortunately you got divorced blah
blah blah what this [ __ ] happens
let's say you found another chick and
you want to get married again would you
still make
obviously you're getting mad i'll be
your best man for your first one would
you still make me your best man for your
second wedding and would you do like the
same similar vows and like invite the
same people invite the same friends
about the same family for another
wedding i'm not getting married again i
promise you i'm not going right again
i promise because he that's all right in
that scenario i have to get married
again baby please i'm this wedding's
done i have to look for the next girl i
couldn't face it again regardless if i
met the girl of my dreams two weeks
later and we were together eight years
after that
and then she's begging me please get
married
every time i contemplate it i would
imagine it happening again that ptsd
will ring like a doorbell oh fam whip me
like a slave
baby that baby please you could never
call your wife baby again oh you can
call another woman baby again
it's darling or babe
baby please
with chest
wow but yeah that was a little um
that was a little snippet
that was juice um
guys we've been watching what did we
watch recently the ambergram being fit
abercrombie and fitch what's it actually
called i don't wanna i don't know why
hot is it called white hot oh hot white
or white hot sorry i think it's called
white hot
let me double check again oh my goodness
um
abercrombie
white hot the rise and fall of
abercrombie and fitch
because we started talking about it on
um
on the episode we did uh
jamie and alex on the private pods
private parts pod and he was like um
have you seen the abercrombie thing i
was like i've seen it but i've not seen
it i want to watch it it would okay cool
before we get into it
when i actually realized what impact
meant
i needed to hold your hand
when they discussed
who was impact and who was modeling
i was like not my boy just just for a
bit of context i used to work in
abercrombie and fitch in probably summer
of 2000 and
my first year of new zealand probably in
summer of 2010 i worked in abercrombie
of fitch and with one of my other boys
and i met one of my other good boys from
there that's where i'm at cheering
cheerleading you met steven there as
well do you
remember i don't remember the first time
you ever met my housemate steve yeah
i actually remember stephen
you both clocked each other in my
hallway and you were like i know you and
he was like i know you and then you both
said i'm coming in fitch oh swear i
don't remember i remember i that's every
time you talk about you working out
because that's all i remember i swear
you and stephen both weren't there
that's mad at the same time mad we
obviously clearly weren't like because
you were there when humble went there
isn't it rihanna's thing
yes yes yes yes the bread outs in um
yeah yeah yeah so he was a mod i can't
remember his name but he was a model
when i was working there hmm it's always
like six four six five yeah he looks
tall yeah and he was he was
he was like chiseled he fit through he
fit the description
so yeah for context back in circle
summer 2010 i used to work in
abercrombie and fitch
and i was an impact and the impact is
you either work on the shop floor or you
work
in the stock room area sorting stuff out
is either that or you're a model and i
wasn't a model so yeah but yeah yeah
you're on some backstage thing um so
anyway yeah yeah literally the context
of abercrombie fitch if you haven't seen
it guys netflix
i think it's called white hot white hot
the rise and fall of avocado rising fall
and of abercrombie and fitch is
basically that
the um
the journey from abercrombie fitch being
taken over by their
now previous ceo i can't remember mike
jeffries mike jeffries [ __ ] wow yeah
he's a gay racist guy wow so basically
he changed the company so that
they only it was like he tried to make
it the most exclusive company so like
if you're fat or black or asian or if
you just don't fit a very he basically
wants all american yeah that was the
first just wanted to he was basically
hitler i just said i want blonde hair
and blue eyes that's all he wanted he
wanted an arian race of models for
abercrombie fitch
and he basically said like this is what
i define attractive
if they don't meet these standards i
don't want them in the shop i couldn't
care less i just don't want them yes i
don't want them in the shop
so um that obviously triggered down to
like senior management middle management
managers etc
and basically they had to be as
inclusive as possible without actually
like breaking the law so what they would
do is hire if they hired a black person
they would just give them less and less
hours
as it went on and hopefully they would
[ __ ] off or put them on the night shift
put them on the night shift and clean
the windows she said she's i can't
remember her name but she said the
manager said oh but babes you're so
you're just so good at cleaning windows
i'm punching you in the face i promise
you that man
i'm punching you in the face i promise
that now
you're just so good at cleaning when
you're so good at cleaning windows are
you sure you want to swap shifts
i don't want to clean windows anymore i
have the same job as cheryl
cheryl says she wants to swap she wants
she loves cleaning windows please she
wants this four-hour shift i wanted
today i want to be here facing customers
and she said
we just don't have the slots
wow
i don't want you swapping and we don't
have the slots if you're not paying
enough and bearing in mind to give
abercrombie their jews it wasn't just a
racist thing you could be white and not
make it as well
you just had to be peng you just had to
be his definition of paying
if you're not his definition of paying
you're not working here you're not
fitting the bill so basically that went
on until there was a massive cry out
of everyone being like this is racist
this is exclusive this is
this is non-american this is you can't
you literally can't run a business this
way so he flipped it and said all right
say less
we're going to employ as many black
people asian whatever as you want ugly
people as you want but we're going to
employ specific models who hit our
criteria criteria if they want to be a
model here they have to hit these
criteria and it just allowed them to do
whatever they wanted the same thing
they've been doing yeah but because it
was under model and impact
you can work here but you need to work
backstage
customers can't see you
and i remember when we were talking to
jamie about it and he said he was an
impact man said he wasn't allowed to use
the stairs
because he said he was in a stock room
and i was like i'm surprised because i
was on the shop floor or you could do
both but more time i was on the shop
floor like rearranging clothes making
sure guests were okay or customers were
okay blah blah blah yeah yeah yeah i'm
thinking damn they say don't use the
stairs don't use the stuff people might
see you there use the back lift use the
elevator in the back
fam
it was nuts where we where we put the
pallets and these that's when they um
they introduced that like diversity
inclusion manager away i can't remember
about that yeah so there's friends yeah
then they have the diversity inclusion
no no no because actually no tell a lie
because
the i'm pretty sure the model the model
impacting came after the diversity yes
of course after that yeah yeah
and then it all kicked off
it was with the racist t-shirts when it
kicked off
two ones can make a right
white white sorry two two ones gonna
make it white white i was like wow so
yeah they kept having so basically they
would release these t-shirts with
slogans on them that people seemed to
love
and a lot of them were racist like a lot
of them had was like a
a donkey with like a sombrero on it
basically towards the asian community it
was just yeah harmony racism the latina
and asian countries got it and then like
the one that like
brought the camels back was literally
one that had two like giant like
stereotypical like racist chinese
caricatures and the slogan was uh in
like a dry cleaners or something and the
slogan was two wonks can make it why
that's the most racist thing i've ever
heard i couldn't in my entire life i
couldn't believe it and that that would
have gone through so many
levels of of pass obviously yeah yes
okay yes that's fine yes that's fine yes
that would have been through so many
people
yeah they came out and said that one of
their designers was asian and they asked
him is this all right and he was
apparently he gave the go ahead but the
other brother yeah if i'm making 100
bags a year abercrombie and fitch and
i'm the only black person there
i
run me any t-shirt you want under the
peer pressure i've loosened my job yeah
because i already know how to treat
people that look like me here yeah i
really know that people yeah i'd be like
yeah it's fine whatever under like
you've
no he doesn't offend me yeah personally
he doesn't pay for me i understand i
can't speak for my race yeah it doesn't
offend but you know what else are you
going to say in that situation possibly
at that time as well
it's tough man and it's it's surprising
how we got away with it for so long yeah
for so long but then the thing that that
changed it all was when that filipino
brother
did like a summer shift and then went
back to do another shift
after like the next year and then the
manager was like i can't rehire you
because we've got too many filipinos
already in here and she didn't he didn't
even tell her he's filipino
she she just one look at him and was
like we're full we're we're good on
filipinos
i'm gonna throw it out there we're all
good on filipinos
bye
we've hit our quote on our diversity
sanity and i don't want you back that's
insanity and uh who's the brother i used
to take the pictures i can't remember
his name the other guy gainer yeah the
other gay guy
taking pictures of the guy that did all
the photography or most of the
photography for abercrombie fitch that
you see in there in their stores and
stuff
he would lure the guys in oh my god he
would lure the guys in wouldn't he just
he would bail him say oh come to come to
my villa come to my spot we can chill
have a few drinks you can play with my
dogs blah blah blah they're on location
yeah yeah yeah
playing my dogs whatever children one of
the brothers said i'm okay no it's fine
i'm good i'm bro i'm good hung up said
five minutes later he got another call
from like management
he said pack your bag you're done pack
your bags the flight is at x
my jaw would drop
oh i'm suing
the thing is this dread because it's
done over the phone you can't you
literally can't like um
you can't use it as evidence
there's no transcript there's nothing
nothing
there's nothing
you're just done
i couldn't believe it bro he was the
other brother the other
the other model when same same camera
guy the other big model he was like the
hand on the chest he said let me know
when you i'm gonna go down let me know
where you feel uncomfortable i'm gonna
take your hand and you're gonna smooth
it down your body let me know when you
feel uncomfortable man said here and he
said my hand didn't move
he said no no no no no no let me know
i'm gonna move it down we're moving down
your torso let me know when you feel
that cocktail big man
my hand
listen your hand's not moving down my
comfortable now right now we haven't
moved oh my god get your hands off me
right [ __ ] now
yeah so yeah their main photographer
love to [ __ ] the models i couldn't i
can't remember his name but i couldn't
believe what i was witnessing
but the same brother as well he said um
he got scouted or whatever he's like oh
yeah you look you're the type of look
when looking for an abercrombie he said
man has never flown before the next week
he was in mexico
to be fair when they when they showed
the pictures of him he was above you
yeah they were the skullcap shoulders
man had shoulders on it you see what i
hired him he was above you [ __ ] hell
yeah he was like yeah
he looks like he works for like a dodgy
wrestling
federation he held onto that muddled
thing as long as he could yeah yeah yeah
oh my god the only thing that's lasted
is his hair yeah
he found he went through it out because
he said that man used to beg for
homeboy's attention they'll climb trees
but he said everyone used to just [ __ ]
yeah yeah you should just just [ __ ] and
he would just take candy you just take
candy takes candace and that's how we
just get them and then
he'd pick the model he wanted and he's
banging you tonight come back to my
donut today
the the whip will be outside in five
jesus that's two that
i will be terrified for her brother in
another country i don't like
confrontation either i know i'll be
terrified
i
would need your support if you had look
at me i need your support because i'll
i'll hang on the phone tell exactly what
happened
i said i don't know what to say
i don't know what to say he told me the
car's out here i i wouldn't have the
balls to be like i'm good
there's a car going to be here in one
minute it's on the epstein team
he's on an epstein thing
i don't know what to say i don't know
what to do yeah i've heard rumors i
think he wants to clap my cheeks he will
clap your cheeks
he will
like i literally need someone to tell me
trust me you'd rather lose this job and
get [ __ ] by an old [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's when i realized just for clarity
that's just for clarity i promise you
it's the only time i'd realized right
you're right
right you're right you're actually right
because before we've said that before i
was contemplating [ __ ]
how much do i need
to flow
because you might not have a whale of a
time
and i'm liking what i'm saying yeah yeah
i'm like there's titties up in it
titties everywhere and there's palm
trees and teeth nothing comes for free
that's
that's how i grew up
i assumed everyone every man is gonna
get their turn until you told me it's
not worth it
it's literally not worth it
no so if i didn't have
specifically you in that house i know i
would have got my ass clapped
i would have come back waiting for whose
turn this next to find out it never
happened to anyone ever he just wanted
you
until he bails me again next week
imagine i'm kidding him imagine
that's when i'd kill him
when i realized it's not a turn
it's not a duckduckgoose thing a whole
week has gone by and he's belgium again
next wednesday james round two
outside what i'll say through hasn't
been once
he hasn't been wasn't like who who
he doesn't even know me on a first-name
basis he just knows me as that black guy
who
well okay ignore him david hasn't been
ryan hasn't been
who are they get in the car
i want that golden skin
i want that throat again
i promise you i'm committing murder that
night
i promise you'll commit a murder that
night
unless i said who hasn't been once
i promise you
there's not a lot of
duck a la ranch in the world
that's stopping me from killing him
oh
man him
[ __ ] i'll go crazy bro [ __ ] that sweet
me
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that guy indeed bro
anyway
i had one
i had one frustration with that thing
my one frustration
which also kind of ties into my
frustration with council culture
and it also ties into my the fact that
like i can have whatever opinion i want
on someone
but i appreciate like i respect their
fact to act how they want to act okay
because i i believe
in i don't believe in fate but i believe
in justice
and i believe people's
people's time will come and their
comeuppance will come so basically it
all happened with that filipino guy
right
so filipino guy got pied
because they said you're two i've got
too many filipinos
so he went home
went online and basically started this
petition thing did he do diligence did
his due diligence and got all these like
people rallied together
signed all these petitions to make them
change how they're acting and i was
watching all that and i can appreciate
why they would do such a thing right
but my thing is is like
why would you want to waste so much time
on energy
on a company that doesn't want you
so like my thing is is like if i turned
around and was like
i
hate black women okay that's just let's
just say i hate black women i hate them
and then my dms are full with people
trying to convince me why that's the
wrong thing to do
just give up on me
i'm not worth it i've just proven to you
i'm not worth it
i hate of course i get that but it's
also a sense of
that's all that's very different because
you are saying you hate black women so
that's some that's something you've
stated so you're in a position of power
because you've said that whereas i'm
receiving the information from you you
work in abercrombie i'm receiving
information from you saying i can't hire
you because you've got too many black
people yeah yeah i'm [ __ ] offended
you're not offended yeah you're
offending yeah yeah there's a difference
i get that but what my point is in terms
of like
the what i get that they're trying to
spread the i the point that i supported
was them spreading the word yeah that
abercrombie ain't [ __ ] yeah these men
are racist they're sizes they're
alienating 60 of their market they
literally only want white customers they
don't want white employees
[ __ ] abercrombie don't shop there i
don't work there i appreciate that
sentiment what i didn't appreciate was
that we need to sign a petition so we
can get thousands of signatures together
so that i can go to their head office
and tell them
you need to change your ways it's like
for me it's like
they they're not stupid they know
they're racist
like yeah but
you're basically saying you need to
include more black people
so more black people can work for you
and make you more money it's like
they're not going to stop it like mike
jeffries is clearly a racist yeah he's
not going to stop being racist just
because you said you're you can make
more money if you make x double xl
clothing you can make more money if you
hire more filipinos in these areas he's
basically like cool well i can still be
racist
i just
you're just making me more money yeah
but it's like
my thing is let them burn out no but
don't give them money it's different
because i get that but also
mike jeffries didn't create abercrombie
and fitch i get that but now the
company's stealing [ __ ] anyway because
they've got this tarnished reputation
yes of course of course they should have
thought of that about that before they
hired him in the first place
like whoever's the ceo ceo of
abercrombie and fitch now was always
going to be it's a lady yeah yeah she
was she was going to make it yeah let's
just she was going to be fine
like coming off the back of that you're
always going to be better yeah yeah yeah
it's like whether she got the
abercrombie job or another job or
another job like she was gonna be all
right yeah it's like it's not like the
creator of abercrombie was some disabled
guy who had no voice and mike jeffrey
swindled him and ruined his brand it's
like they actively hired mike to do his
job mike [ __ ] it they got rid of mike
he got like a 26 million payout yeah
he's nowhere to be seen he's not he's
living in the bahamas just chilling
right he wasn't even he didn't win
who the [ __ ] i've not even seen an
abercrombie saw in the last 10 years
the only thing i've seen is hollister
because it's like the system yeah yeah
yeah same thing holistic and there's one
other one yeah so i my point is i get i
get i get what you're saying but yeah my
point is is that like i don't like not
even just to do with amber comic i don't
like when people come in
same on a council culture thing
it's like if for example if you said
something that you believed in your
chest and it was
outrageously offensive
i don't believe in in the 11 people you
offended on twitter going to the youtube
headquarters and being like who had a
prick because of xyz so youtube said you
don't deserve to make videos anymore i
believe in the however many thousands of
people that enjoy you as a person
changing their mind about you and be
like i no longer support this guy
[ __ ] this guy
let's all stop watching him and let
cause because that's what i mean in
terms of
i believe in true justice yeah i believe
in the i don't believe in the minority
making a loud noise and everyone being
too afraid to confront them
so they just let them carry on
i believe in the actual majority being
like
[ __ ] this guy
and then just moving away but
i think i hear what you're saying don't
get me wrong but it took
that filipino guy and a group of people
that signed a petition or whatever that
came to that um that boardroom meeting
for that to happen to instill some form
of change because at the end of the day
mike jeffries quit
yeah he's designed from his pose because
but mike jeffries is just the head of
the i don't think i know all the
shareholders are still making money and
blah blah i think there was only one
black guy the inclusion diversity
inclusion brother and then
as well yeah every that's the thing it
started at
jeffries but you cut the head off the
snake but every level below him in
between floor in between floor level in
between manager level that said we hired
too many filipinos and they still
decided not to quit
every there all the way up to whoever's
directly below mike jeffries are still
making racks till now
in my opinion
all of them deserve to be [ __ ]
anyone who let that two ones make it
white t-shirt go through to production
all of them none of you managers deserve
to make money anymore yeah and as soon
as that filipino guy said you deserve to
change your ways no one got sacked apart
from mike mike didn't even get said he
just didn't turn up yeah he just didn't
turn up on monday and he got a massive
payout yeah so mike's still making money
all the senior managers are still making
money everyone's still making money by
doing this kind of like we need to be
more diverse we need to change our
mindset it's like you're not gonna
they're not idiots this wasn't like in
1960 this wasn't like 2014. yeah it's
like they knew what they were doing they
knew they were being racist they knew
they were letting mike just get away
with murder no one stepped down and said
listen this guy is [ __ ] i'm not
working for him no one said that they
all allowed all that racist [ __ ] to
happen or the exclusionary [ __ ] to
happen they still stayed there they
still got paid and all that happened was
one brave filipino guy came in and said
you may need to change your ways and
then they changed it and they still got
paid and they're still getting paid or
now yeah true true so nothing's changed
their mindset hasn't changed it's it's
uh when you say like that it's a bit
weird but it's also a good watch as well
just like oh it was a good watch a good
deep dive on what the background of a f
and predominantly what other
big big big um clothing brands could
potentially be like you know it's mad
but a f were extreme
because obviously i work there so i know
like they they wanted a at that time
when i was there
i think it was way after this thing
because it was summer 2010 so in terms
of like me thinking or that they're
being racist or being or racial
profiling was nil because there were so
many black people there oh so many
people of color there yeah yeah and it
was just a mix black models um asian
models like mixed rate like there was so
many so i didn't deep it as much as what
i'm doing now after watching this show
you know so it's clear that the um
diversity inclusion whatever manager did
what he needed to do to make sure that
other people didn't experience this
so
looking back at it i can kind of
unders
okay there was a this is just a one-off
like i remember
i think the summer after so maybe summer
2011 i reapplied because i wanted to
work you know yeah yeah so you know what
i'm like i've always worked yeah i've
worked for time yeah yeah so summer 2011
me and my boy ivy and cheerlead i think
we all reapply but on separate times you
have to go for a process where you i
think you handed your cv said if you
worked it before blah blah blah
went through the proper interview
process
and then they were talking to everyone
talking to everyone in a group thing and
then one of the brothers asked me
um oh you've worked here before right
and i was like yeah i worked here in um
summer last year as an impact he's like
oh did you do the night shifts
off the bat i've never thought about
this until now oh
off the
bat he was like oh where you doing well
you must have been doing or something
along those lines but he said night
shifts i was like nah i was on the floor
as a regular regular
employee but i can't remember how the
conversation went after that he was
thinking no you won he was like
oh that's impossible that's impossible
that's against guidelines yeah that's
against rules and regulations
so how how how
are you sure you're on the show during
the day how you swindled yourself into
the shop floor but it's not going to
happen on my wall he must have thought i
crept up yeah yeah i crept up you took
the stairs when you went out when i
wasn't when i wasn't allowed
you said you better stay in the back
that's probably why i didn't get hired
again probably because you're probably
not going to stay here because if you
think you're coming on shop floor this
time on my shop floor you're twisted you
think it's coming on my shop floor this
time around
i'm ripping up your cv here and now
you're mad i couldn't believe it
obviously i didn't deep in much then
yeah i didn't deep it at all but it's
only just come to light now wow yeah bro
wow wow indeed
anyway let's have some funny fun let's
stand let me piss again and then we'll
do that yeah oh i need to piss as well
actually right guys um a couple weeks
back i know last week i didn't do a um a
question but don't worry we're gonna
we're gonna read it back next week um
but a few weeks back i asked you guys
what's the weirdest sexual request
you've ever heard
and um yeah
man said use your teeth while sucking my
dick oh my god wow bro random
i got sucked up in a toilet cubicle
years ago when i was like 19.
i think you've said the story before but
girls toilet cubicles yes i think you're
right yeah yeah asian girl remember and
she literally said do you want me to
bite it
as she was sucking me off she stopped
looked me and mastered me to bite it and
i was just like
no
of course of course i don't like
allegedly literally of course i don't
what the no and the fact that she even
asked that and i had to say i don't ever
want to be in a position in a sexual
scenario where i have to say no yeah
it should always be yes
as soon as i have to say no i digress
yeah
so as soon as she was like joining the
bite and i was like no i was no longer
interested in this place oh [ __ ] hell
he he told her to be rude shout out him
in a pub shout out him in public beat
him and make him drink his own piss
wow
he pays for that
he pays for that online i promise you
that for a fact now he pays for that
online
he wanted me to snap his banjo aka
foreskin by biting
excuse me family that's what i read and
that's what i wrote
snap it as in
i'll just ping it back just no
no no no that's impossible that's
impossible it's impossible yeah
no
the captain of the local rugby team
asked me to shove the hotel remote up
his bum
as soon as he said
anything goes when i say rugby anything
goes i was not surprised by that rugby
man initiation different they do
anything yeah so yeah that's light for
him he's had baggage up there yeah yeah
the first message a guy sent to me on a
dating site do you like anal fisting
wow bold brother very bold he knows what
he wants yeah and he's not gonna stop
until he gets until he gets it someone
will say yeah yeah yeah someone will say
yes
and that night oh oh yeah it's off
coming off yeah yeah he asked if he
could wear ladies underwear suspenders a
lot
we don't kink shame but wow you don't
but wow
i was asked to stand on a guy's ball
sack with my heels on it was a no from
me blocked
fair fight
when are the yats going to speak up
when are the females going to ask for
something
this is disgraceful behavior
when are they going to ask for something
by
i'm not gonna lie to you he asked me to
send him a video of me wetting myself
i can't even laugh at these bro
carry on please my ex wanted to try and
ask me to shove a pencil up his arse
what's going on with the man them carry
on to [ __ ] in a box so he could eat it
he asked me to peg
he asked me to peg him wearing a bunny
mask and a latex suit on our first date
i'm not laughing at any of these bro
carry on they're surreal to me
asked if i could dip my toes in peanut
butter and he'd lick it off like a dog
[Laughter]
wow [ __ ] hell this girl didn't let me
[ __ ] until i stuck my big toe upper arse
we [ __ ] four times that night i bet
they did
i bet
this is why this is this is why there's
no guys messaging because they don't
have a problem with any of it
they don't have never a problem
[ __ ] that's hilarious there's not a
problem with any of it they don't even
remember these things happening because
there was no issue whatever she said it
was a turnover it was a yes and he
nodded
he ate night like that before
[ __ ] oh god my partner want my partner
will never lick my nipples he said
because you breastfeed that's my son's
food
to be fair
if you're like if you're in that
like uh that time of frame we've had a
you and they're still breastfeeding i'm
not sucking to either because it's milky
yeah yeah it's literally milky
i'm not in that situation i don't know
what it's like but i can only yeah it's
milky it's milky i'm not taking that
risk that's yucky
that's yucky i don't know
he wanted me to dress up in lingerie and
have me film while i [ __ ] him with a
dildo then fake threatened to send it to
his wife
he was once fake threatened he was on
some uh sub dumpty yeah yeah i'm gonna
send this to your wife so he could be
like please no no no no no no no he's on
the floor begging please no no no no
don't send it
it's like
no he was in lingerie brother
imagine you dressed up in lingerie
suspenders getting banged
and then she said i'm going to say your
wife and i'm like no no please please
please please like [ __ ] beg me beg me
with a hill on my forehead like a
[ __ ] uh wolf of wall street yeah yeah
yeah beg me please don't
don't send it oh my goodness he asked to
[ __ ] my armpit and belly button
moving on he saved up his [ __ ] in a
bucket
in a cupboard for a good week
then asked to pour it over a woman i
said no
in sanity
this chick used to say
thanks for your donation after giving me
head wow that's bath that would send me
west that's bath wow i'd shake
wow
thank you for your donation after
swallowing it thank you for your
donation
oh
wow my heart will be twice
wow
could i bend could i bend her over in a
ski mask and cut her back so she can
feel the blood run down her [ __ ]
okay this is that's dark this is too
much
i was told by an older woman that if i
wanted her she'd give me head whilst i
was taking a [ __ ]
that's disgusting
i found out a girl i worked with used to
let her man [ __ ] in her mouth and then
[ __ ] it
how long are we going to do this for
sorry
how many how many more have you got
there's a few more okay give me three
more tops there's a few i can't i
literally i can't keep doing this
got an offer for 800 pounds to throw up
in a mouth to throw up in her mouth she
said black guy's vomit tastes the best
i didn't want to laugh carry on
some guy offered me 150 pounds to flem
on him for 10 minutes
[Laughter]
yo
last one wrap it up i want to get out of
it i can't squish mashed potatoes
between my toes with warm gravy before
giving him a foot job
yeah all right guys [ __ ] hell anyway
guys head on over to patreon.com
turn your phone off
you think it's a joke lock your phone um
patreon.com
for a thursday episode
um
that i
yeah no words no words guys um we'll see
you next week man thank you guys
yeah yeah love love
[Music]
you